bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire la nouvelle création
des baies 3 juniors s'appelle à bout de
souffle mais la compagnie elle ne l'est
pas jean djemaa de l'un des cofondateurs
nous parlera de l'actualité des black
blanc beur elle a 12 ans il en a 13 et
vivent tous les deux dans les yvelines
et léa et dylan font partie de la
quatrième saison de the voice kid
ils seront avec nous en plateau des
marionnettes pour en sont d'autres ports
adultes aux clayes-sous-bois elles ont
envahi l'espace philippe noiret le temps
d'une exposition très vite et geneviève
dichamp le théâtre montansier à
versailles fait cette année sont deux
cent quarantième anniversaire
au programme des conférences des
lectures des représentations et des
expositions
cette exposition a d'ailleurs commencé
ce week-end à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine regarder le théâtre
montansier c'est avant tout une histoire
de femmes
la première marguerite brunet dit
mademoiselle montansier elle crée ce
théâtre qui prendra son nom inaugurée le
18 novembre 1777 par louis saez c'est un
théâtre qui est la particularité d'être
entre la ville et la cour c'est ce qui
fait sa spécificité il est d'abord
situer géographiquement entre la ville
de versailles et le parc du château
et il accueille au sein du public à la
fois des membres de la cour et des
versaillais qui viennent assister à une
programmation extrêmement riche
près de 180 objets retrace l'histoire de
ce lieu peut être moins connu que
l'opéra royal ou le petit théâtre de la
reine des documents d'époque issus des
collections de la ville dont une lettre
écrite durant la révolution
dans cette lettre au moment où la
montansier est en prison elle essaie de
se justifier auprès dès révolutionnaires
et elle va inventer prétendre qu'elle a
était révolutionnaire avant la lettre en
accueillant les parisiennes
théâtre de versailles durant les
journées d'octobre le 20e siècle est lui
aussi marqué par une femme marcelle
tassencourt qui le dirigera avec son
mari thierry monnier de 1961 à 1992
marcel tassencourt était à la fois
comédienne metteur en scène elle a été
vraiment une passeuse de théâtre à
versailles en étant à la fois la
directrice du théâtre elle a enseigné au
conservatoire et la forme et un certain
nombre d'élèves qui sont aujourd'hui
assez assez célèbre certains comédiens
d'autres noms comme françois de mazières
l'actuel maire de versailles ou bien
encore muriel mayette qui dirige le la
villa médicis à rome
le théâtre montansier se dévoile à
travers ses programmations ses succès
ses scandales ou encore ces rénovations
un anniversaire fêté aux archives
communales de la ville avec nous ce soir
en plateau trois invités et léa et dylan
les deux jeunes chanteurs participants à
zéro et ce qu'ils ont soir et janvier
mad des black blanc beur alors on va
débuter avec vous jean mais première
question vous les connaissiez ces deux
jeunes talents voire non je les connais
pas mais j'aurais pu mais je ne suis pas
c'était millions dont j'ai quand même
entendu parler
donc voilà c'est pas la peine de
raconter des bêtises mais bon je suis
ravi de faire leur connaissance exemptes
de bonne bouille et même une bien belle
énergie
alors là bas on va parler des blue
bombers cette saison et la jeunesse
aussi que en avant chez vous puisque les
23 et 24 septembre à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin les baies 3 juniors vont
danser à bout de souffle
si je me trompe pas ça raconte un
périple de jeunes immigrés la
chorégraphie est signée mathieu taïwan
c'est un sujet d'actualité d'abord on
regarde un extrait chi
à
c'est la deuxième création mais la
deuxième création des betteraves des
baies 3 juniors alors j'aimerais quand
même rectifié chose de 23 et 24 c'est à
dire samedi et dimanche c'est une un
petit extrait d'avant-premières dans le
cadre d'une opération sportive 500 tv
sport organisée par donc lille le loisir
mais la première elle même elle a lieu
donc le 29 septembre vendredi à 20h30 à
l'espace albert camus ne mord pas voilà
alors justement deuxième création ont
continué sur les baies 3 juniors il ya
une dizaine d'années on a recommencé le
processus je dirais de spectacle école
que nous avions mis en oeuvre dont il ya
plus de trente trois ans maintenant et
qui a permis à de jeunes danseurs du
territoire de saint quentin au départ
est à nouveau cette fois-ci de devenir
des professionnels tout simplement en
apprenant leur métier à l'intérieur d'un
spectacle l'intérêt c'est évidemment
d'avoir une motivation puisque spectacle
on la prend pas pour rien on va le
montrer et c'était vraiment la version
du spectacle de fin d'année c'est que
quand ça quand le seul le premier
spectacle arrive c'est le début c'est
pas la fin alors ce sont des semi
professionnels vous avez lancé c'est
important de concrétiser aussi les
peut-être les pépites que vous repérez
oui enfin c'est important déjà d'offrir
une des savoir-faire une virtuosité une
capacité une qualité d'énergie qu'on a
su construire ramener ici du tyne et
dans le monde entier et la met aussi à
la disposition des habitants de saint
quentin
là où on vit à trappes à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de la remettre
à disposition de la qualité de notre
récit territoire voilà c'est ça qui est
important
et à l'intérieur de ça ce qui est
important c'est de permettre à des
jeunes qui ont un talent une capacité de
pouvoir accéder au plus haut niveau et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure
d'offrir ce processus alors juste avant
qu on continue et on les a pas vus parce
qu'on diffuse l extrême et
dylan et avait l'air assez impressionné
vous pratiquer la danse hip hop où tous
les deux mais enfin vous voyez ça vous
dit que il ya beaucoup de travail
oui il s'avoue donnerait envie peut-être
pourquoi pas ce sera exempt passion dans
le dans le milieu de la chanson on
retrouve certains chanteurs qui danse et
qui chante donc si assez important et
les baies 3 c'est pas que déjà annoncé
que des jeunes d'essayer danseurs
dopantes 50 ans qui dansent encore et
c'est une équipe principale qui a été un
tout petit peu en panne ces deux trois
dernières années parce que nous avions
quelques soucis de structure et c'est
donc une pièce qui se prépare pour d'ici
la fin 2010 8 qui pour le moment la
forme d'un duo ce duo donc que qu'écrit
christine coudun la cofondatrice et
chorégraphe de la compagnie avec moi qui
a formé matière à gwen qui a formé boris
bodonon qui est l'assistant de mathieu
et qui lancera la médiation sol humains
et donc nous sommes sur un processus là
d'écriture pour christine c'est
véritablement comment dirais-je à
travail d'abstraction sur la stylistique
de la breakdance fait avec des danseurs
qui ont une maturité extraordinaire une
respiration à la fois de maîtrise du
ralenti mais aussi du lent comment
diriger une maîtrise qui est le témoin
de leur maturité humaine et elle nous a
montré un quart d'heure le 29 avril
dernier au centre mandat pas dans le
cadre d'une nuit de la danse et je pense
que tous les gens qui étaient là ce soir
là se sont sentis privilégiez donc
aujourd'hui avec le centre
chorégraphique de créteil celui de la
rochelle avec la maison des métallos à
paris et avec je l'espère nous allons en
parler plus finement prochainement avec
l'odyssée scène conventionnée qui
s'occupe du festival mimos à périgueux
nous sommes en train de construire un
processus qui va peut-être être à du
haut d'une dune heure duo
en sol majeur ça s'appelle peut-être un
sextet
tout ça est en cours d'évolution mais je
vous reprends travail parlez vous avez
mis en avant beaucoup partenariat et
vous en faites
outre avec black blanc beur vous faites
aussi avec le cadre du sable et vivre
debout toute prise en compte
un petit mot là-dessus prises en compte
c'est laventure des 40 ans de
l'association vivre de bouc est une
association qui regroupe des handicapés
très très lourd sur des fauteuils etc
qui ont besoin d'assistance en
permanence pour la plupart et nous
connaissions dans les débuts de la vie
nouvelle nous avions travaillé ensemble
avec le théâtre de l'unité et au moment
leurs 40 ans ils ont fait appel à nous à
moi etienne aux artistes du territoire
pour faire la fête
et depuis cette fête nous ne sommes plus
quittés à nouveau puisque nous sommes en
train de décrire à la fois un spectacle
le spectacle de l'histoire que nous
vivons de nouveau ensemble cette
aventure c'est celle d'abord des
habitants des friches 17 mar d'elancourt
mais aussi de montigny plaisir bientôt
c'est à dire là de nouveau une
transversale dans le récit du territoire
où nous amenons à sor d'esthétique
sortes d'exigences bas des histoires de
tous les jours et ouvrir la danse à tous
c'est finalement là c'est un exercice de
danse de théâtre il ya du mime
il ya du masque que nous amène etienne
bisch à étienne amène aussi son gérant
géant de 4 mètres et c'est donc on
retrouve toutes les formes de spectacles
vivants de spectacles de rue qui sont
dans l'escarcelle dans la mémoire que le
théâtre de l'unité nous a laissés ya une
quarantaine d'années
merci à jean djoman alors pour découvrir
l'actualité de la compagnie le site
alors le site trop faible www.slate.fr
vous pouvez aller aussi sur prise en
compte
point org br i s le n
comptez au ntfs point org pour vous
verrez et puis notre fonds parlera dany
masseaux ce qui est un regroupement
d'associations 50 ans auquel nous avons
participé et que je voudrais souligner
parce que je pense que c'est un outil
supplémentaire
pour le rayonnement de la ville et pour
ce que nous essayons de faire depuis des
années toute une grande activité à
suivre à faire une petite pause et je
vous propose qu'on reparte à versailles
direction cette fois équestre elle a
rouvert ses portes le week-end dernier
après une pause estivale et pour cette
rentrée une nouveauté une visite de ses
coulisses avec un guide conférencier
camille lambert s'est encore de ballet
équestre avec ces artistes qu'ils soient
humains ou chevaux à l'académie équestre
de versailles
fondée par le chorégraphe bartabas
ladies écuyers et leurs montures forment
un couple uni des années sont
nécessaires pour arriver à ce résultat
la relation entre l'écuyer le cheval
c'est vraiment la base du travail ici
c'est pour ça bien sûr que bartabas
lui-même va essayer de choisir quel
écuyer va monter quel cheval avec des
respects de proportions physique mais
surtout de caractère donc ça s'adapte se
sont tous les matins que les écuyers
passe une heure à faire travailler
chacun de leurs chevaux chaque écuyer en
moyenne 4,5 monture à faire travailler
un travail que les curieux sont invités
à découvrir lors de visites guidées
vous avez le nom du cheval vous savez ça
rase et ici
le menu une plongée dans les coulisses à
la rencontre des stars du spectacle
comme baby les experts en cabrioles ou
des salles d'importance ce que j'appelle
toujours le saint des saints
c'est à dire la sellerie est un lieu
extrêmement fermé d'habitude mais qui va
permettre de voir les selles les
harnachements et tout au long de la
visite on va tout simplement voir le
travail on va voir les palefreniers au
travail on va voir les écuyers venant
chercher leur cheval
le prépare en lui parlant on va voir la
nourriture des chevaux également donc
c'est vraiment le quotidien à l'intimité
l'intimité de l'académie martin ans tête
accueillera des groupes de 30 personnes
maximum pour partager ses secrets et
anecdotes sur la vie à l'académie les
visites sont proposées tous les
dimanches à 10h30 sur réservation
et on continue cette culture avec nos
deux autres invités et à et dylan je le
disais dans les titres vous avez 12 et
13 ans vous êtes tous les deux de
l'aventuré the voice crise de l'émission
de tf1
première question déjà comment vous en
êtes venu à participer à l'émission
et oui à l'heure
j'avais posté une vidéo sur youtube
quand j'étais à pitti d'un concours de
chant et simplement envoyé un mail pour
me recruter pour l'émission pareil pour
toi de la même alors au moins dans
j'étais parti pour faire un spectacle de
fin d'année
il se trouvait que dans ma commune y
avait un producteur qui travaillent avec
ces veilles c'est donc il a envoyé un
mail aux aux casseurs des foils qui m'a
repéré vous êtes jeune quand même en 12
et 13 ans c'est pas un peu
impressionnant grand plateau comme ça et
devoir séduire patrick fiori jennifer
matt pokora qui selon les artistes
peuvent être de votre génération enfin
ce que vous écoutez
il est vrai que c'est impressionnant
parce que on débarque on est injuste de
voir le plateau on n'a pas impressionné
par les 3 suit les trois sièges tout le
public mais après au bout d'un moment on
s'habitue et les à toi sur ton audition
à l'aveuglé trois jurés se retourne et
tu joues tu les moulins de mon coeur de
michel legrand aux curieux pour une
je me fais de tournage bat peut-être que
enfin les autres jeunes filles de mon
âge
écoute d'autres chansons bah moi aussi
j'ai coûte 2 500 mais c'est tout
simplement mes parents qui m'ont fait
découvrir et j'aime beaucoup cette
chanson je trouve qu'elle avoue que
d'émotions et j'avais envie de changer
un peu de régime
et en plus cette chanson tu l'a chanté à
l'estaminet en 2015 mais mes amours oui
on voulait un extrait alliés comme une
pièce que l'on jette
dans nos vies d'un ruisseau
et qui laisse derrière elle
des milliers
dans l'eau
comme un manège de lui
avec 7
je vous dis toi
alors aller à la paix a company avec un
nombre de familles un petit mot je
travaille beaucoup et que cette personne
je crois sarthe a commencé la guitare
très tôt dans la musique depuis tout ton
enfant joui des filles chez tout petit
je joue d'un instrument je chante mes
mains toute ma famille fait ça donc oui
j'étais plongé très tôt et bat j'adore
ça
son nom j'ai tout de suite aimé ça le
toit d'olonne la chanson pour coiffer
alors moi c'est venu comme ça enfin j'ai
pas du tout de ma famille de chanteurs
sauf d arrière arrière grand père ou
grand mère mais ouais c'est tout
simplement avec ma mère on écoutait
beaucoup de la musique voilà on adoré ça
et après c'est moi qui ai pris recchi a
pris goût et en attendant venez vous
êtes tous les deux dans l'équipe de
patrick fiori vous avez pu travailler un
peu ensemble ou ce que vous faites pas
les battles ensemble comment ça s'est
passé
la suite après après que vous entrez
dans l'équipe de patrick fiori c'est
quoi ce sont des répétitions fait on
fait beaucoup de répétitions avec déjà
des coachs vocaux qui sont à l'extérieur
qui nous aident beaucoup qui nous détend
ya il ya plein de gens autour de nous
qui nous aident et après on a des
répétitions un peu spéciale avec nos
coachs mais qui seront un peu plus
amusante et tout ça on fait plein de
trucs et voilà l école moment le collège
consent se passe on vient vous en parler
on vous pose deux questions 8 lutins à
chaque fois d'un lac où il ya des ja des
plus petits ou des flux rend d'ailleurs
qui viennent le voir qu'ils ne disent
alors ça c'est passé c'était génial ou
des choses comme ça on a eu énormément
de gens qui nous rend connaissent
surtout à la cantine on évite de nous
voir et nous disent ce que je peux avoir
un autographe qui fait suivre jusqu'à
chez moi
un élève déjà des stars déjà fort refuse
autographes on forme ont poussé alors
vous avez pas le même parcours
samedi dernier c'était les banales et
les as tu n'as pas été conservé par
patrick par patrick fiori ben oui mais
c'est quoi la suite pour toi bats la
suite belle soirée où c'est pas grave un
gsm si je vais quand même peut-être
avoir une énigme et tu veux continuer
dans la chanson ou c'est une expérience
que tu vas t'en servir pour autre chose
je sais pas trop encore mais sûrement
j'aimerais bien devenir chanteuse mais
je ne sais pas encore mais peut-être
peut-être vous pourriez travailler
ensemble peut-être un jour c'était
peut-être la rencontre je suis sûr que
vous avez vous en avait déjà parlé tous
les deux et j'aimerais les vraies
passions moi j'ai un album qui se
prépare donc je suis en préparation et
un 6 buts avec mon producteur et je me
disais qu'il fallait forcément qu'ils
aient au moins duo ou deux je me suis
dit baye lahad très près de chez moi
donc autant discuter et voir avec elle
tu te rappelles toi
eh bien si alors tu parles et bientôt un
album qui est en préparation parce que
toi dylan tu continues
patrick fiori tu as gardé sur téva
talent mais il ya un autre projet autour
d'un artiste est pas nécessairement ta
génération michel sardou pente en haut
vues là dessus
alors en fait baisse voice a continué
tout ça et dans la foulée j'ai reçu un
appel donc d'un producteur qui me disait
qu'il était intéressé par mois et qu'il
aimerait en fait me voir dans un album
dans l'album voilà michel sardou et donc
du coup fallait que je passe au moins un
casting pour qu'on puisse vérifier
j'ai passé le casting et j'ai été pris
avec d'autres personnes de the voice
deux autres masses de matière on serait
et les kizuna et id et d'autres talents
comme nemo schipman durba et lou telle
promotion gens j'ai mal je vais en
profiter vu que vous recrutez vous
découvrez des talents il faut le
découvrir à ses taux un talent pour
pouvoir le faire travailler
la similitude déjà entre notre aventure
et the voice ou un certain nombre
d'émissions qui sont nés ces 20
dernières années est frappante tire le
fait d'être dans un processus de
pratiques et d'évaluation permanente
je pense qu'on a initié ou remis aux
goûts de roue du jour ce qui autrefois
s'appelle radio crochet et c est ce qu
il est important de détecter tôt c'est
toujours mieux
mais des fois tôt et mal ça peut être
pire que tard et bien c'est à dire au
moment où la personne est disposée
capable de bien re situer son parcours
dans l'ensemble de sa vie dans
l'ensemble de son environnement
donc il ya pas de recette dans la sphère
vous êtes dans un univers différent
c'est la danse et le chant mais c'est
l'art c'est la scène un petit conseil
que vous auriez allant donner
s'accrochait travail et le conseil c'est
de prendre de très sérieusement ne pas
prendre ça au sérieux
peut-être si je dois en donner voire
même pas un conseil disons une
suggestion
parce qu'en fait des conseils il faut
jamais en donner malgré leur âge et leur
petite taille elle vit là absolument la
même chose que tout les gens qui
viennent se mettre excusez moi
l'expression à poil un randonnée devant
tous les autres c'est que ce soit devant
cinq personnes
en 2000 c'est exactement la même
question qui se pose je pense que leurs
maîtres l'ont appris ça il reste c'est
ce qu'on se disait en coulisses tout à
l'heure pour respirer
merci à tous les trois dates données en
plateau pour parler de votre actualité
dylan
on va suivre tes aventures et les on
espère te revoir très vite peut-être
avec un album ou un autre concours
pourquoi pas et du côté des black blanc
beur la nouvelle création dv3 l'île des
loisirs un petit morceau mort pas
surtout le 29 1er septembre alors que je
vous invite les filles là pas de soucis
on a tous on va changer de sujet on a
tous un jour jouer aux marionnettes
alors bérengère gilberto et hubert
jappelle en ont fait un avec le théâtre
de l'usiné fondée par hubert jappelle
des marionnettes pour enfants des
créatures des créations pardon tout
public une exposition à l'or est
consacrée à l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois regarder
[Musique]
je construis que
christophe chanter les marionnettes en
bérengère gilles berton elle les crée
elle travaille la mousse les plumes ou
encore le tissu à 19 ans j'ai fait mon
premier spectacle de marionnettes
complètement naïvement mais c'est
souvent pour l'instant autour du conte
du récit de la jeunesse au fur et à
mesure des années je me rends compte que
pour l'instant j'ai pas vocation à
monter des textes comme hubert a pu les
monte six bérengère gilberte ont créé
autour de l'enfant hubert jappelle son
mentor travail des textes plus complexe
plus adulte c'est une oeuvre qu'hubert a
monté toute sa vie c'est à dire qu'il a
dû commencer à essayer de trouver
l'adaptation du procès de kafka a même
avant 30 ans il a commencé à travailler
le texte
il a travaillé même sur des parties de
deux textes en comédien il l'a jouée en
comédien ensuite il a essayé plusieurs
fois en marionnettes
les deux artistes invitent à une balade
dans les secrets de la création
un univers que le public pourra
agrémenter de représentation et
d'ateliers
[Musique]
cette semaine on se rend au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa de saint-cyr-l'ecole
bertrand pigné nous donne son coup de
coeur regarder alors le coup de coeur du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine il
s'agit du film skaff holding qui sortira
le 18 mars prochain sous le titre les
destinées de la chaire est donc vous
l'avez compris ce qu l'avant-première
c'est une avant première d'un film qui a
été repéré par l'acide qui est l' agence
du cinéma indépendant pour sa diffusion
c'est un collectif de cinéastes qui
repèrent des films qui les amène à
cannes et qui nous propose de les re
découvrir en salles et du coup pour
accompagner ce film qui du coup est
quasiment inconnu mais qui est un grand
film vraiment un très très beau film on
a aura le plaisir d'accueillir le
réalisateur de ce film
matagne haïr qui est israélien et qui
viendra donc échanger avec vous sur son
film sa manière de faire du cinéma
comment il a rencontré cet acteur que
vous allez pouvoir découvrir dans ce
film qui est vraiment un acteur
exceptionnel parce qu'il s'agit de
l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui va être
pris entre son père qui souhaite qu'il
reprenne l'entreprise d'échafaudages
familiale et puis sa découverte tout à
coup d'un d'un jeu d'un professeur de
littérature qui va l'ouvrir
au monde et puis évidemment il ya un
retournement de situation dont je ne
vous dis rien qui va bouleverser tout ce
petit équilibre
donc je vous invite à venir le samedi 23
septembre à 20h30 pour découvrir ce film
ait rencontré son réalisateur matagne
haïr au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
à très bientôt un autre rendez vous
cinéma lui j'essaie de saint quentin en
yvelines a cette fois fabrice éboué
viendra présenter ce dimanche son
dernier film coexister regarder si dans
moins de six mois monsieur musique n'a
pas rempli le lapi avec un nouvel
artiste
il cédera sa place de directeur et
pourquoi vous fais pas ça un prêtre un
rabbin et un email
réunis sur scène pour chanter ensemble
non mais je rigole pas là
la rentrée c'est aussi celle des salles
de spectacles celle du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines se fait avec
trois rendez-vous les grands formats
samedi c'est fred pallem à 18 heures
avec des reprises de musiques de dessins
animés de films d'animation le soir ce
sera print and friends la rentrée débute
avec loïc antoine lantoine vendredi 22
septembre regarder
[Musique]
je courais très très vite après le
premier cheveu blanc de la plus belle
ceinture
quand tout à coup et pour voir du
théâtre direction plaisir et le théâtre
espace coluche la louve raconte les
coulisses de l'accession au pouvoir de
françois 1er et le rôle de louvres la
mère du futur roi regarder dans
l'attenté ce qu'annonce de voir un jour
mon fils monter sur le trône d'autres
gros car son cahier de champion de
france avec lignot que j'apprécie
surtout les femmes blondes mais j'aime
les brunes tout autant quant à ses
recettes des pays du nord keldélice si
l'occasion s'en présentait je vous le
dis tout à trac je trouve très
volontiers de logistique le peu de cas
que mon époux fennecs
il serait bon que vous vous préoccupe
acier - des appâts de notre jeune
souveraine et que vous vous intéressiez
davantage à ceux de votre époux le 7 une
culture est maintenant terminée vous
pouvez revoir le magazine sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile
je vous dis à mercredi prochain
[Musique]